The general going experience,
but do you ever feel that it's almost like you're absorbing too much because you
are looking at all the problems of all the people,
seven plus billion around the world and all these different horrific injustices?
I try to focus on what I can do and what I can do is,
is challenge my own government. And you know,
as an American citizen living in this society,
I think that the U S empire and the Pentagon is the source of a lot of problems
around the world. I look at the world as complex.
I mean you have to understand the issues that are going on,
especially with foreign policy in terms of the colonized and colonizers,
the oppressed and oppressors and the U S his role as well as other previous
Empire's role in shaping the world as it is today.
And a lot of the problems that have arisen are because directly us foreign
policy, whether it be the global war on terrorism,
whether it be terrorism in general, I mean that, you know,
drone strikes basically cause terrorism, whether it be the environmental crises,
the Pentagon is actually the largest polluter in the world,
more than 140 countries. That's essentially every country in the world almost,
um, a bigger polluter than the top four chemical companies combined.
So it all kind of stems back from this notion that, you know,
the U S is the world's largest empire that's ever existed and it needs to be
stopped to save humanity. And so as an American citizen,
I look at all of the problems and I understand that there is like a very common
route and I can do something about this common route.
And if you're looking at domestic problems, the lack of healthcare,
the lack of education, I mean, Martin Luther King called it decades ago.
He says, you know, a,
a nation that spends more and more on military spending is facing social death.
I probably butchered his quote, but that's essentially the spiritual death.
I think he's what he said. But I mean,
that's exactly what's happening is when we're squandering all of our money,
bolstering up this huge global empire,
we're not taking care of our people at home, our brothers and sisters at home.
My empathy extends as an internationalist all around the world. I, I, you know,
I feel for my brothers and sisters in Palestine, Yemen, everywhere.
But I can only do what I can do based on what my government is doing.
And, and you know, it's doing a lot.
It's doing a lot of horrible things and it's time for us to really acknowledge
what those horrible things are because we need to reinvigorate an antiwar
movement in this country.
And when you're saying that drone strikes create terrorism,
what you're really saying is that, well, what people,
if they don't understand drone strikes primarily kill civilians,
right? Well, it's a,
it's a really crazy number and it's this very strange,
sanitized way of handling an issue where if you had a person and you had some
Rambo character, you send him overseas, you said, Hey,
I want you to go get this ISIS terrorist. And uh, in the process,
kill everybody. The fuck that you see everybody that's in front of them,
that person would be a war criminal. All right? If you had a guy,
and he knew that some ISIS guy was in a, an apartment building,
so he just started gunning down men,
women and children in that apartment building until he got to the terrorist,
that guy would go to jail.
But if you do it with a remote control and you launch hellfire missiles out of a
drone and it blows up the apartment building and kills all these innocent
people, but also gets the terrorist, it's mission accomplished. And it's crazy.
It's crazy that we're signing off on that, right? And what gives us the right,
it's to kill people. It's, it's a thing because we're not there.
Where there's this weird sort of a, just a,
there's a a bridge that we're allowed to cross into this really sickening act.
It's a very,
when you have anything that's ineffective to the point where most of the people,
it kills our good people, or at least are innocent people we should say.
That's crazy. I mean this is not saying that there's not terrorism.
It's not saying there's not horrible people in Iceland is absolutely right.
You look, I'm a pro military person.
I think we need military and I think just like the same I need, we need cops,
but to deny that cops sometimes are bad is fucking crazy.
To not deny that.
Sometimes when you allow the military industrial complex to do things like have
drones that launch missiles into wedding parties because you think one of the
people might be a terrorist and are often incorrect,
often to the tune of 90 plus percent. Yeah. It's crazy. Yeah, and you look at,
you know, the last 10 years,
you look at some of these terrorists who have conducted terrorist acts.
You look at actually what their intention was and a lot of them,
the vast majority literally cite us foreign policy, revenge, us foreign policy.
I mean, every time you kill 98% innocent people,
whoever survives,
if you lost your whole family and that you have an incredible amount of
motivation to get back at whoever did it right and that whoever did it is the
United States. We need to stop normalizing this. And um, you know,
militarily speaking, Trump actually, you know, it's not just Trump.
I mean this is a bipartisan effort throughout the entire Congress.
If there's one thing Congress can agree upon,
it's to make nonviolent BDS efforts against Israel legal and also to just keep
ramping up the military and ageing on whoever's sitting in the oval office to be
more militaristic. And that's exactly what's happened with Trump. Um,
in a bizarre way. I mean, Congress approved like a seven, uh,
near trillion dollar defense budget and the increase alone in the last year was
basically Russia's entire military budget more than Russia's entire military
budget. That's how much this shit's ramping up.
And then you have the space force. I mean, it's just like,
how far is this going to go? The society is collapsing.
If you looked at the argument against this, you would say,
we need this in order to keep people safe here.
That would be the argument against it. My question would be, what are we,
what threat is there ISIS?
When has ISIS ever done anything here other than, I mean,
there was like a truck. I mean, come on.
We already know the statistics on terrorism in this country and they're very
low, right? I mean you're,
you're basically more likely to die from like furniture falling on you or shore
apartment. Yeah. Yeah, and the whole ISIS thing. I mean, as we know,
ISIS have Rose out of us foreign policy, the failed state and Libya,
the Iraq war, that's still criminally ongoing. I mean,
Trump announced this indefinite extension of the criminal occupation of Iraq.
It's just crazy how normalize this is. You know,
far longer than Vietnam were in Afghanistan.
Fatalities that aren't all time high.
All of these things are a direct result of us foreign policy and look at the
refugee crisis. Look at immigration. The Honduras, CU,
all of this shit's connected and that's what we need to start like expanding our
consciousness and our empathy worldwide to understand all of these things are
linked and the struggle is all linked and our world is shrinking really rapidly.
What candidate speaks in this way?
Like what candidate do you think understands and recognizes all these things
that you're talking about?
I mean, Mike Ravel is the only one who's like, we need to end the U S empire.
Bernie and Tulsi Mike Ravel was a,
he was the guy who basically read the Pentagon papers and directed he, he's,
he's a good guy. He is. Yeah.
He has like this online campaign that's really awesome,
but I mean Tulsi is speaking a lot about regime change Wars,
which is extremely important, but she still believes in drone strikes.
She basically has a little bit of Obama's foreign policy that I don't agree with
that fundamental understanding.
Did drone strikes like maybe if there's an ISIS camp somewhere. I mean,
I can't believe that she believes in some sort of a just broad brush use of it.
I haven't looked into the nuances of that, but I do think that, um,
no one is saying what I want them to about us empire, about, you know,
scaling back the U S empire and stopping all of this civil society movements
because it's not just about invasions anymore. It's about, you know,
you surpassing the democratic processes of all of these countries like what
we've done in Venezuela,
what we're doing all around the world to try to foment unrest. Um,
all of this needs to be stopped.
Do you foresee a time where our dependence on foreign oil is radically reduced
to the point where it doesn't justify these regime change Wars and our
dependence on these resources that these people have? I mean,
this is almost every conflict in the world.
You can boil down to the acquisition of resource,
right? And also the protection of capital. And that's like what a lot is.
What a lot of it is now is actually just capital interests needing to expand and
grow and to up increase the profit structure of these corporations.
And that's exactly why we've seen imperialism, you know,
kind of go out of control in the way that it has. I don't know.
I mean I thought that we were more independent oil wise.
I don't think it's good. I think that climate change, yeah, I think that,
and it hasn't stopped, you know, it hasn't stopped the imperialist, um,
misadventures of the U S government.
So I think there just needs to be a really big shift in consciousness and people
to stop thinking that it's our right and that we have, you know,
the right and the duty to do this around the world.
It doesn't give us the right, we don't have it. It's not right, man.
It's really not. And, uh,
we need to really reinvigorate the masses here because again, um,
society is collapsing. That's pretty fucking obvious.
Well, if it is, if it's not obvious,
what is obvious is that we're not evolving in terms of if we're still involved
in drone strikes that kill 98% of the people,
if we're still involved in regime change Wars,
we're still involved in these unnecessary military actions against Iran.
It's these things that people freaking out about.
This is all the same kind of shit that people have been fighting against
forever.
That we don't want our brothers and sisters and husbands and wives to die for
nonsense. We don't want them to die.
For some people that live in these air conditioned rooms that are making
billions of dollars that are profiting off of the actions of these,
these noble people who think that they're doing it to protect America.
I mean, this is the narrative that they're being served.
This is what they're being told and when they're going to these places,
they're not going to those places to act as evil as, as to as the, the,
the boots of some empire.
They're going over there because they think they're protecting freedom.
They think to protect and their family and their loved ones back home.
That's why they're doing it. If we're still doing that, we're not evolving.
Well,
I mean that's what's so scary about the Iran thing because the people who are
surrounding Iran and being directed to go out there,
they're the ones who are going to be the sacrificial lands for these defense
contractors.
And I don't think that you can argue anymore that this is for freedom.
I mean, how can you, what threat does Iran pose to the world?
So it's a tough sell. I don't, I don't understand what threat they serve either.
And what, what benefit would it be for them to start some shit with us?
And this is the craziest idea ever. I mean it's like my, you know,
a nine year old kid trying to pick a fight with Mike Tyson's.
I'm crazy. It doesn't make any sense. Like what are you trying to do?
I'm trying to get killed.
I mean inevitably we're trying to get to the global confrontation with China and
Russia, I guess. I mean that's,
it's scary to think that we only have a couple independent States left to knock
down to be under complete subjugation from the U S military and global
capitalism. Pretty nuts.
Well, not only that,
even if we do move into some sort of a,
some sort of a situation where we're in control, then we're a bigger target.
And with the amount of nuclear weapons that are possessed by these countries
that were, I mean,
just what North Korea has just this one small fucked up country could ruin life
on earth.
Just this one country and forget about Russia.
We could literally annihilate each other. Right? That's, that's a possibility,
right? I mean, if, if someone chose to launch an attack,
if they decided that they have the justification to launch an attack and then
all of a sudden we're in a real war, like a fucking war war
invading us, shit's getting knocked down. Buildings,
bombs blow up. I mean, over what,
this can't be avoided. This is the only way.
The only way is missiles and bombs. Like you said, we're not evolving
or devolving. I mean it's, it's unbelievable.
We have the capacity to provide for everyone. We have the capacity to cooperate,
to innovate and we're stuck. We're stuck dehumanizing the other.
We're stuck with this mass conditioning to basically perpetuate these,
these injustices. And it's really a shame. I mean,
we have all the information at our fingertips,
but we still keep reverting back to what's the myths,
the myths that underpin our society.
These conversations I have with you are so depressing because it's always,
I always leave going, what, what can be done?
What can we do? What, where does it end? Where does it go?
You know, these are, these are the big questions. And then also the,
what we discussed before,
it's impossible for anyone to really have a deep nuanced understanding of all
these different issues. Right? Right.
I mean, I think focusing on what you can do,
we can only do what we can do and you have to understand that, you know,
you can't get debilitated or disillusion with, you know, the,
the influx of information or just the complete, you know,
the heaviness of it all. You just have to do what you can do.
You're doing what you can do. You have me on to,
to help spread awareness about these issues. And that's when you it
and you're about to get it.
You're about to get spammed with a lot of Hasbro and I don't have my real email,
but that's,
that's what we can do, Joe. And,
and you just have to live your life and provide for your kids and,
and love what you have and, but also just understand your place,
you know, and, and just extend the empathy that you can and just, yeah,
I mean it's, it's hard because I don't have the answer.
All I know is what's needed and what's needed is we need a movement of the
masses. It's not going to come from the top down. Um,
it's going to come from a grassroots mobilized effort to try to change these
policies. That's the only way things have ever in the past.
And I absolutely have hope and optimism that we're going to change things and
that we're going to correct this horrible path that we're on.
Do you think that the 2020 elections can have a real significant impact of any
of this?
Do you think that whoever gets into office can really have an effect on the
kinds of policies that we're talking about with the kind of influence of the
military industrial complex of all these lobbyists of wall street, [inaudible],
all these like ma monstrous machines that just pure,
good old fashioned democracy can actually step in and,
and turn this ship away from the rocks.
Bernie, I really do think that he's one of our last chances,
not because I think that he's going to completely do some revolutionary upheaval
from the top down. As we know,
Congress is stocked with a lot of terrible people who will block a lot of these
efforts, but I think that, um,
he's going to mobilize the masses and reinvigorate the labor movement and
reinvigorate unions and help workers understand that they need to fight for
these rights that have been eviscerated. You know,
over the last a hundred years.
One thing that does inspire me as well as seeing people like Ellen Omar,
you know, she is incredible. She's a Somali refugee.
She advocates BDS against Israel and she does not fucking back down.
I love that woman. What an incredible woman. She got vicious,
viciously attacked for retreating. Um,
one of my episodes from empire files.
And I think it just shows how scared people are of, of her and her ideas.
And you saw how hard everyone came down on her for just saying that Israel has
an influential lobby in D C
yeah, well the,
she's also wearing religious garbs that people are scared of that right away the
job. And then, um, there was something, some hippies on her yesterday.
They're saying they think she married a brother. Oh, that's ridiculous. Yeah.
They think she did to get into this country that she had a religious marriage,
but then she had another, yeah. I don't know.
She's the only one in Congress other than [inaudible] and of course AOC and um,
you know, some other very few people,
but she's out there every day speaking against the military industrial complex,
speaking against the Wars. I think as a refugee,
she understands the effects of us policy.
And I'm really excited that she has a voice in there. But again,
I don't think that the hope is going to come from within Congress.
And the system is way too far gone with the electoral college and the
gerrymandering and the voter rights, you know, that had been rescinded. It's,
it's a lot and it's an uphill battle, but that's why someone like Bernie,
I think, will turn to the people and say, I can't do this alone.
You have to come out and get my back.
And we have to have millions of people in the streets demanding these things.
That's the only way it's gonna work.
[inaudible].